-You look fantastic.
Happy belated birthday,
by the way.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-Yeah.
You brought something that --
that related to your birthday,
because your kids made you
something very special,
that's something you enjoy,
that I'd never heard of.
What -- What is it --
What is it called again?
-A chip butty.
-Yeah, a "chip butty."
Any guesses?
-Whoo!
-Has anyone ever heard of that?
Yes!
-Yeah, you're just saying that
to talk to Naomi Watts.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, of course.
I love chip butties."
Yeah.
What is a chip butty?
-Okay, so --
-Or "chip butty."
-Butty, yeah, double T...
-Okay.
-I-E or Y.
Um, so it basically
is a delicious snack
that you devour
when you're super hungry.
-Yeah.
-And, you know, it's often
after swimming lessons,
we used to have it as kids.
And my grandfather decided
that this was a funny prank,
rather than giving us birthday
presents or Christmas presents,
he would make us delicious
chip butties
and put them on
the Christmas tree
or wrap them up in tinfoil and
have them for birthday presents.
Anyway, it's french fries,
which we call chips
in England...
-Yeah.
Birthday presents, you said?
-Yes, yes.
-So you would get this
as a gift?
-Yes, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Did they, like,
wrap up the sandwich?
-We were happy about it!
-No, of course!
It's great!
You open it up, "Oh, my --
it's a sandwich."
-Yeah, yeah.
-Wow.
-It's a delicious sandwich.
-Oh, it's fantastic to get.
-It wasn't something
that he would be bothered
to make us, so...
Oh, you have it right here.
See?
This is --
[ Laughter ]
-Can I just -- okay.
It looks like --
[ Laughter ]
Is it -- am I missing --
am I missing an ingredient?
-Well, is there salt and pepper
and vinegar on there?
'Cause it's gonna
be dry otherwise.
-Well, no, I think that'll
probably be on there, maybe.
-And butter.
Don't forget butter.
-And "butta."
-Yeah, not butter.
-Not butter.
And it's butty, not a buddy.
-Exactly.
It's a chip butty -- "butty."
-The T's are T's, not are D's.
-Chip butty, with "buttah."
Not butter.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Are you gonna have a bite?
-Yeah, of course.
Would you like one,
or do you want me to --
I can just --
You look too nice.
-Yeah, I'm not gonna do that
with my red lipstick.
-Yes, you look too good.
Yeah, here we go.
A chip butty, which is really,
honestly --
I feel like it's a sandwich
that's missing something.
-Let me just --
[ Laughter ]
-It's --
I understand the idea of it.
I just feel like --
-Do you ever put fries
in your sandwich?
-On a hamburger, yeah.
I feel like -- like,
at McDonald's, yeah.
But I feel like
that's the part I'm missing.
-Right, right.
-All right, let me just --
Here we go.
Do I put ketchup on it?
-Well --
-No, it has vinegar and salt.
-It has the vinegar and salt.
-It sounds like torture,
actually.
It's very interesting.
No, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Do you need to dip it?
-You need to do something to it.
[ Laughter ]
-Something -- maybe some beer.
-You know,
maybe if it was wrapped --
maybe if it was wrapped
in gift wrapping,
I'd be like, "Wow!
Unbelievable."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-This is my first butty.
-Here you go.
-Thank you.
-Good -- Good job for trying.
-Of course I would try it.
-You need a beer chaser.
-I do need a beer chaser
with that.
I always love new foods, so
thank you for bringing that on.
But I -- that's the first time
and the last time, you know?
[ Laughter ]
But -- joking.
-My grandfather would be
turning in his grave.
-No! If grandpa made it for me,
are you kidding me?
I would love it.
Are you kidding me?
But no.
All right, let's discuss.
Next time, I'll --
-We can move on.
-Next time, I'll give you
a sandwich that I like.
-Oh, God.
-I don't know
what that would be.
-Yeah, what would it be?
-Probably would be a hamburger
with french fries on it.
[ Laughter ]
With Halloween coming up,
do you get into
Halloween costumes?
-Yeah. I never used to
do much for Halloween.
It's really an American thing.
-Oh, it's great.
[ Laughter ]
It's so fun.
-It's fun.
-You're gonna love it, yeah.
You go door to door,
and you wrap up sandwiches
and give it to each other.
[ Laughter ]
-That could be the trick.
-"God, another butty, yeah."
-That's the trick.
-You go, "Oh, my God.
I have 300 butties
in my pillow case."
-"Don't knock on my door again."
[ Laughter ]
-That'll be the last --
they'll throw eggs.
Absolutely.
Don't give out butties.
But -- But I was like,
"Can you -- Can you send us
a picture of a costume
if you ever got dressed up?"
-Yeah.
-And you did have a costume.
Was this last year maybe?
-That was last year, yeah.
-That's very cute.
You were a cow.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Very -- come on.
That's the way to do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
I thought you were gonna
go with something scarier.
-Yeah, I've done scary before.
-You have?
-Definitely.
I like to change it up.
I just try to find whatever's
lying around in the house.
I didn't have that cow suit
[ Laughter ]
-You -- You specially ordered
that cow suit.
-I did -- I did order that one.
-Yeah.
-But you do things --
we've talked about this --
where you're kind of
a daredevil, and I go,
"Oh, I could never do that."
There was that one photo shoot
you did for "King Kong"...
-Yeah.
-...on the Chrysler building.
-That's right.
-Do you remember that?
-Oh, yeah.
I'll never forget that.
-You stood on the top
of the Chrysler building.
-Yeah, right on the gargoyle.
You know, the...
-Yeah.
-...the bit that sticks out,
that's only about that wide.
-But that -- was it frightening?
Out of your mind?
-Terrifying. I -- I don't know
what possessed me.
But my agent and manager were
there, and they were saying,
"You don't have to do this,
you know? You don't."
And I was like, "Yeah,
why don't they Photoshop it?
This is insane."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly, yeah, exactly.
"You just greenscreen me
on top."
-Yeah, yeah.
-I mean, the ape isn't real
in "King Kong."
Hello!
[ Laughter ]
"Use the same technology.
Put me on top of anything."
-Yeah, right -- well...
-None of these --
-It's one of those buildings.
-Yeah, you grab one.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
You could be on the top of it.
-And, um, and they said,
"No, they really want to do it.
It's a special story.
They want to know that it's
really happened."
And I got up there,
and I looked down, I was like,
"No way.
I cannot do that."
That's just -- makes me sick.
-You looked down.
That's the problem.
-Yeah.
-You can't look down.
-And then I -- something came
over me, because my assistant,
who's kind of, at the time,
was super athletic
and daredevil herself.
And she said, "Oh, I'd do it."
And I went, [ Gasps ]
"Okay, I have to do it.
I can't be a chicken."
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Are you competitive?
-I have a competitive streak,
yeah.
-Yeah, you do, yeah.
You've never been that
competitive with me, have we?
-Oh, well --
-A few times.
-No, we played ping-pong.
What -- What's that game?
Beer pong.
[ Laughter ]
-I was like, "I've never
called it ping-pong."
[ Laughter ]
"We played ping, pong."
-I knew it wasn't ping.
[ Laughter ]
-But that's right,
we played beer bong.
Oh, yeah, it was a little
competitive there.
-I think I beat you.
-Yeah, I don't remember.
But --
[ Laughter ]
I want to talk about
"The Watcher" because, man,
I think you -- you can do it,
you can do it all.
But when it comes to the
thrilling, and the scariness,
you nail it.
This thing is crazy.
And it's super secretive,
by the way.
-Yeah.
I'm not allowed to say anything.
-I know. You're not.
But I'm allowed to.
-Go on.
[ Laughter ]
-I think it's about a family
who moves into a new house?
-Yes.
-And they start getting notes...
-Yes. From someone
in the neighborhood.
And it's a story...
-Called The Watcher and says,
"I'm watching you."
-...a lot of New Yorkers
are familiar with, or a lot of
Americans I suppose, yeah.
-It's frightening.
-Yeah.
-You get -- and it's like,
"I'm watching you.
Signed, The Watcher"?
-Yeah.
And they -- they've moved
to this home thinking it's gonna
be their dream home, you know,
out in the suburbs
with leafy green streets,
and, you know,
it's a beautiful house.
-But it's so frightening.
-It goes terribly wrong.
You couldn't say anything
about the show, but last time
you were on our show --
Thank you, again --
you said you were doing
pottery lessons for something
you were working on.
-Oh, yeah.
-Can we say that you
do pottery in this?
-Yes. You -- you're right.
I debuted the reveal.
-I got the scoop?
-Yes.
-I got the exclusive.
Get ready for pottery, guys.
All over --
[ Laughter ]
No, but I was laughing,
'cause we did it last time --
I was --
-You were great.
-No, come on, now.
[ Laughter ]
We actually, weirdly enough,
we saved the pottery
of what we both made.
We both -- We had a wheel
out there, we were learning.
And I just wanted to show you
the finished products.
You haven't seen it
since you've been here.
-I haven't seen this.
-This is yours.
-Well, very unfinished, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kind of cool that way.
Actually, I love that.
And then this is --
this one was mine.
[ Laughter ]
And I just thought...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Very interesting.
So they both turned out
kind of --
-Not bad.
-Not bad at all.
-Some improvements
could be made.
-I want to give this to you.
-That's -- really?
-For your birthday.
-This is beautiful.
-Yeah. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I could -- [ Laughs ]
-I'm getting choked up.
-I love -- yeah.
I love it.
-You -- what -- what is it?
-I think --
-What could you do with it?
-What could we do with it?
-You could, um,
hold your keys maybe in it.
-Yeah, my jewelry.
I could put my rings.
-Ooh, and incense!
Do you burn incense?
-Yeah, I do.
-You do?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh!
That's perfect.
[ Laughter ]
-Or a candle.
-A candle -- yes.
Put a candle in there.
See, that's actually very artsy.
[ Laughter ]
It's almost like a fish mouth
or something.
It looks like --
-It's some kind of vessel.
-It looks like
the mouth of a bass.
[ Laughter ]
Like the --
-Looks like "The Scream."
-Like -- like I'm an angler.
You know, like --
Oh, I should do a photo shoot,
like, fishing and be like, the
fish is coming out of the water.
I mean, I got the beard.
Now I just need
to start catching fish.
This is actually unbelievable.
This is where you put, like,
I don't know,
extra hooks or bait
or something.
-Yeah.
Well, anyways, this is for you.
You could do whatever you like
to do with this.
-I really love it, Jimmy.
-And we always love it
when you come here.
Thank you so much.
"The Watcher," everyone...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...premieres October 13th
on Netflix.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show,"
everybody.